simplify negative 1 times this
expression in brackets negative 7 plus 2
times 3 plus 2
minus 5 in parentheses squared so this
is an order of operations problem and
remember order of operations you always
want to do parentheses first parentheses
parentheses
first then you do exponents
exponents and there are there is an
exponent in this problem right over here
then you want to do multiplication
multiplication and division and then
finally you do addition and subtraction
so let's just try to tackle this as best
we can so first let's do the parentheses
let's do the parentheses we have a 3
plus 2 here in parentheses so we can
evaluate that to be
equal to 5.
and let's see we could do other things
in other parts of this expression that
won't affect what's going on right here
in the parentheses we have this negative
5 squared or actually i should say we
have we're subtracting a 5 squared we
want to do the exponent before we worry
about it being subtracted so this 5
squared over here we can rewrite as 25
and so let's not do too many steps at
once so this whole thing will simplify
to negative 1 and then in brackets we
have negative 7
plus 2 times 5
plus 2 times 5 and then
2 times 5 and then close brackets
minus 25
minus 25.
now this thing we want to do
multiplication you could say hey wait i
still have a parenthesis here why don't
i do that first but when you just
evaluate what's inside of this
parenthesis you just get a negative 7.
it doesn't really change anything so we
can just leave this here as a negative
7.
and this expression we do want to
evaluate this whole expression before we
do anything else i mean we could
distribute this negative 1 and all of
that but let's just do straight up or
order of operations here so let's
evaluate this expression we want to do
multiplication before we add anything so
we get a 2 times 5 right over there 2
times 5 is 10
that is 10. so our whole expression
becomes and normally you wouldn't have
to rewrite the expression this many
times but we're going to do it this time
just to make sure no one gets confused
so it becomes negative 1
times
negative 7 plus 10
plus 10
and we close our brackets minus 25
minus 25. now we can evaluate this
pretty easily
negative seven plus ten you can view it
we're starting at negative seven
so i was going to draw a number line
there
so we're starting
let me draw a number line so we're
starting at negative seven
and then so this the length of this line
is negative 7 and then we're adding 10
to it we're adding 10 to it so we're
going to move 10 to the right if we move
7 to the right we get back to 0 and then
we're going to go
we're going to go another 3 after that
so we're going to go 7 8 9 10 so that
gets us to positive 3. another way to
think about it
is we are adding integers of different
signs we can view the the this this
sum as going to be the difference of the
integers and since our the larger
integer is positive our answer will be
positive so you could literally just
view this as ten minus seven ten minus
seven is three
so this becomes a three and so our
entire expression becomes negative one
negative one
times and just to be clear brackets and
parentheses are really the same thing
sometimes people will write brackets
around a lot of parentheses just to make
it a little bit easier to read but
they're really just the same thing as
parentheses so these brackets out here i
could just literally write them like
that and then i have a minus
25 out over here now once again you want
to do multiplication or division before
we do addition and subtraction so let's
multiply the negative 1 times 3 is
negative 3 and now we need to subtract
our 25
so negative 3 minus 25 we are adding two
integers of the same sign we're already
at negative three and we're going to
become 25 more negative than that so you
can view this as the as
we're moving 25 more in the negative
direction or you could view it as 3 plus
25 is 28 but we're doing it in the
negative direction so it's negative 28.
so this is equal to negative
this is equal to negative 28 and we are
done